et on en revient maintenant à cette
annonce très importante faite par la
russie aujourd'hui qui pourrait être un
tournant dans cette guerre en ukraine le
ministère russe de la défense annonce
que les forces russes se concentreront
désormais sur la libération complète du
dombass gauthier rybinski comment on
peut analyser cette cette annonce est ce
que la russie va se contenter finalement
delà de la partie est de l'ukraine va
arrêter son offensive en dans le reste
de l'ukraine dans ce communiqué du
ministère de la défense russe il ya
effectivement mention d'une basse et
mention aussi de kiev qui était dit le
ministère de la défense un objectif
possible donc il m'était option une des
options voilà donc ils mettent à un
niveau égal les deux soient kiev soit le
dôme basse alors le donne basse on sait
pourquoi on sait parce que il y a deux
républiques autoproclamées pro russe qui
se sont formés que vladimir poutine
estime que ces républiques représente la
défense des russophones au contre les
ukrainiens sauf que là déjà il ya
quelque chose qui tient pas on l'a vu
depuis trois semaines presque depuis un
mois à chaque fois que vous avez des
personnes qui sont interrogés par la
presse
notamment dans l'est dans les coins dans
les régions où les bombardements étaient
intenses et bien vous avez quantité
d'ukrainiens qui parlent spontanément le
russe et ça n'est pas un problème pour
eux et donc souvenez-vous d'ailleurs de
ce mr le maire de mélie topol qui avait
été kaka kidnappé parlent les soldats
russes et qui s'est enfui ou et en
l'ayant été libérés s'entretenait avec
volodymyr zelensky le président en
quelle langue se sont-ils entretenu en
russe ça veut dire que la la césure et
nico
linguistique à laquelle la nuit à
poutine croit elle ne tient pas donc pro
protéger les russophones aujourd'hui ça
ne veut plus rien dire vous avez même un
mario paul qui est quand même
aujourd'hui la ville martyre de
l'ukraine et bien vous avez des gens et
ça on en a des témoignages et des
preuves très précises des gens qui
encore il ya cinq ou six mois était
totalement pro russe et qui avec cette
agression et cette invasion on retourne
et ont pris les armes contre contre
moscou ça c'est la première constatation
la deuxième constatation c'est qu'il
faut peut-être évidemment plein se
méfier de cette déclaration russe qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire est ce
que ça veut dire que comme on ne peut
pas avancer sur kiev comme on ne peut
pas progresser on se contente d'une
basse et à ce moment là vous allez voir
que l'on va sortir l'argument
humanitaire moscou va dire mais oui
c'est une pour pas plongé dans le
désarroi le plus complet les populations
de l'ouest de l'ukraine que nous
procédons de la sorte donc une manière
de s'en sortir est le plus grand danger
j'en termine là c'est nous qu'est ce
qu'on va faire nous on va se dire que si
poutine renonce à toute l'ukraine on va
avoir un immense soulagement et on aura
raison d'un certain côté puisque ça
épargnera des populations civiles
semences dira aussi bon voilà l'affairé
close et puis on considérera qu'on a pu
amener vous admire poutine à la raison
c'est faux vladimir poutine pour
apporter son regard sur d'autres régions
comme la géorgie ou comme la bosnie
herzégovine ou bosniens et serbes sont
non pas qu'aux habitants mais juxtaposés
et là ça peut redonner de redonner hand
et enfin ça peut renouveler obtenir un
regain de tension donc tant que le
système poutine est en marche bien sûr
qu'on pourrait être soulagés par un
certain nombre d'avancées si elles ont
lieu encore une fois si ce n'est pas un
effet d'annoncé mais le fond du problème
ne sera pas résolu et il y aura bien sûr
la question de marioupol qu'il faudra
décider merci beaucoup gauthier rybinski
pour pour votre analyse